quand 70 ans les réunionnais ceux qui
ont connu la réunion d'avant ils peuvent
eux mêmes en racontant l'histoire de
leur vie voir tout ce que la réunion a
gagné ils ont gagné en matière de santé
ils ont gagné en matière d'éducation
ils ont gagné en matière
d'infrastructures l'état comme l'europe
a beaucoup accompagné le département
là l'ex colonie à devenir au fond 1
un vrai département de droit et je pense
qu'on n'a pas à rougir aujourd'hui du
bilan de la départementalisation
même si l'égalité réelle n'est pas
encore obtenu même si nous avons encore
aujourd'hui beaucoup de public
vulnérable et une grande partie de la
population qui restent sur le carreau
pourquoi parce que nous n'avons pas
engrangé du vrai développement
économique et donc le bilan de ses 70
ans et qu'il faut aujourd'hui pour moi
passer à une autre étape à un autre
modèle trouver les leviers qui feront
que le réunionnais ils puissent aussi
devenir acteur en tout
responsabilisation par rapport aux
français qu'il est il l'est il est un
français à part entière mais il est un
français avec une identité entière
également dans le français que nous
sommes nous avons la culture africaine
nous avons la culture européenne nous
avons la culture un dia océanie nous
avons la culture delà de la chine
chinoise c'est cela le fondement même du
vivre ensemble réunionnais qu'il ne faut
pas au contraire abrogé mais qu'il faut
au contraire peut-être mieux accompagner
pour qu'ils trouvent les moyens en lui
même de son développement personnel et
c'est dedans
trouvant sont des moyens de son
développement personnel qu'on trouve
aussi dans son environnement les moyens
du développement à travers l'activité à
travers l'économie et à travers son
territoire
donc oui on doit passer plus loin la
réunion est un département français mais
nous sommes une île
nous nous avons eu des apports
successifs de population notre histoire
constitue aussi un socle qui nous
permettra de tracer les voies de
l'avenir et pour moi les voies de
l'avenir doivent aussi se faire avec les
pays de la zone de la zone au niveau de
la commission de l'océan indien avec
mayotte les comores madagascar l'afrique
à côté avec nos racines africaines mais
aussi avec les pays du deuxième serre la
chine grand pays déjà fort potentiel
économie et puis l'un également grand
continent d'à côté